être attentif et à l'écoute des
entreprises un impératif pour Charles
Rodwell le député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines a récemment
été nommée rapporteur d'une mission
d'information pour l'Assemblée nationale
il réalise des auditions pour améliorer
les dispositifs de soutien à l'export et
à l'attractivité économique lorsqu'une
entreprise comme produites nous dit
qu'elle a besoin de simplifier les
dispositifs qu'elle a besoin d'être
accompagné à l'export et bien
nécessairement c'est un impact direct
sur le métier de parlementaire tant
lorsqu'on bâtit et lorsqu'on vote la loi
que dans les liens qu'on peut avoir avec
les administrations de l'État pour
soutenir les entreprises pour produire
spécialisée dans l'impression 3D et
leader sur le marché européen ces
visites sont également le moment de
dresser un bilan des dispositifs et de
faire part de ses problématiques
l'intérêt il est multiple attiré
l'intention sur le fait que c'est un
marché qui est très récent qui fait
l'objet les concurrence internationale
qui est-ce qu'elle est par exemple les
entreprises de la 3D dans le milieu
américain sont soutenus par la bourse
avec d'élever de fonds de milliards ou
de plusieurs millions alors que la nôtre
qui date de 2017 était de 60 millions
alors que le déficit commercial a
atteint des records en 2022 la France
demeure pour la troisième fois
consécutive le pays européen le plus
attractif en termes d'investissement
étrangers l'objectif est alors de
poursuivre la dynamique engagée plus
d'une trentaine de visites sont prévues
en France le député a jusqu'à la fin du
mois de janvier pour dresser un bilan